they're the most interesting pornography
of this subject or another interesting
study of cultural and intellectual life
of Ukraine and emigration in Poland
after nineteen twenty I mean emigration
from kia of course by Amelia and visca
PRASA a migratory Nebraska post during
the Ukrainian immigration press in
Poland in nineteen twenty nineteen
thirty nine these are only examples
there are very many books that that try
books and articles that try to need to
analyze different aspects of of this
story of Polish Ukrainian collaboration
against Soviet Russia and Soviet Union
introduced with Pilsudski fedora
agreement but then we have a much more
important probably problem of the
analysis of Polish state policy towards
Ukrainians in Poland it is introduced by
a relatively well documented new
monographie of Polish Ukrainian war in
Eastern Galicia by me how climate ski
that is a kind of summary of
historiography in this subject and after
that we have a series of new books that
continue the line that was introduced in
polish historiography by such eminent
historians as Rosado jet ski in his
quest ii okra a post or am j herlofsky
concept see a political
geovision do polski both of this books
that were edited in the pre also during
the communist times still both of these
books present a Polish state policy
towards Ukrainians in a really realistic
terms showing most of the blunders done
in this policy and analyzing also
context geo political and social and
economic context especially as regards
to jet ski of this policy this line was
different if i can say so by raj
amusement jet ski in his very detailed
analysis of voy a woodstove of india
during the interval period in which he
showed that one of Forgotten elements
that created us pacific of polish policy
towards Ukrainians was the very weakness
of the Polish state it was weak and
that's why many measures Polish state
introduced in its policy towards
minorities Ukrainians in the first place
were a kind of compromise mostly very
unhealthy compromise between grandiose
plans and very weak means to realize
this plans nevertheless man jet ski in
his analysis of civilizational social
and economic development of Boeing Vanya
during the interwar period stresses that
however there were many blunders in poly
Polly cedar both education communication
roads and so on role of intelligentsia
in many respects we can talk about real
development even in this region of
Poland and there is one question that
might be or should be post comparative
question in which part of Ukraine on
which part on which side of the border
this social civilizational and national
development was more restrained for
Ukrainians or more positive for
Ukrainians it is a question that has to
be addressed both by I think polish and
Ukrainian history ography there are also
several books that might be treated as a
kind of answer to to this nail
nationalist publications I mentioned by
preuss or polish joke among this
positive answers to this challenge I
would like to mention very recent book
by Roman vysotsky historian from Lublin
that presents in the most probably
detailed monographie in any language
organization of Ukrainian nationalists
in Poland in 1929 1930 9 it was ok thank
you sir and he presents this
organization as without using any
abusive words without using any abusing
comparisons for example with Nazi
organizations that were used by pros and
by others neo nationalist historians
dealing with this subject in Poland
previously or we can mention another
very interesting monographie by another
historian from crack of Andhra djemba
who deals with Ukrainian polish
relations in Canada among among
minorities which he does without
neglecting very strong connections
between Canadian Ukrainians and
organization of Ukrainian nationalists
but at the same time without so to speak
demonizing this aspect of Polish
Ukrainian relations there by the way I'm
JM x is also the author of many studies
that try to recuperate if I could say so
the great person of Andre kept its key
as a both political and spiritual leader
of Ukrainians in Poland in the end I
want to mention it two books that might
that might serve us as a introduction to
final generalizations one of them is a
book by Valdemar pero odd consolidates e
pine straw a token solid consolidates in
Arad of a consecrated to polish from
pusat seaside state policy applied to
Ukrainians and monk others minorities in
which he stresses again very efficiently
the subject that is neglected in many as
I as I know Ukrainian
books on the subject namely geopolitical
context of many changes and twists of
Polish national policy towards
Ukrainians so to cut it short actually
the most fierce anti Ukrainian stand
this policy took in two moments when
Poland felt herself the weakest between
the Soviet Union and Nazi Germany then
Nazi Germany that is nineteen thirty and
nineteen nineteen fifty-one and then
1938-39 actually 1931 it is just before
Poland managed to recuperate its
relations with the Soviet Union and then
in 1934 with Germany and of course what
1948 is sorry 38 and 39 mins for Poland
it is not necessary to mention here in
as regards to a political position of
power so again a weakness is the source
of many decisions take